To all the Halloween-heads out there, you
should probably start following Jamie Lee
Curtis' social accounts immediately they continue
to be ground zero for glimpses behind the
scenes of the anxiously awaited slasher flicks
Halloween Kills and Halloween Ends.
"Happy Halloween!"
The iconic scream queen, who portrays Laurie
Strode in the Halloween franchise, has been
quite busy on her socials since Halloween
Kills officially kicked off production in
September 2019.
So far, Curtis' posts have largely been still
shots taken on set or in her trailer, like
this Instagram post, which Curtis captioned,
"NEVER SAY DIE!
First day back in the battle for my life!"
It appears the spooky time of year has the
Halloween Kills star in the sharing mood,
though, as Curtis recently took to Twitter
to offer Halloween fans a tasty treat: a 21-second
video that marks the first in-motion look
at Halloween Kills.
Curtis tweeted,
"‘Tis the season..... to start screaming.
First look at the mayhem David has created
for all of you."
Needless to say, but it appears a bloody bad
time is in store for the Strode clan in the
upcoming sequel to 2018's Halloween.
Penned by David Gordon Green, Danny McBride,
and Jeff Fradley and directed by Green himself,
2018's Halloween served as a direct follow-up
to John Carpenter's legendary slasher classic
of the same name from 1978.
Set a few decades after the events of Carpenter's
Halloween, the 2018 movie found Laurie Strode
a little older, a lot grayer, and so deeply
traumatized by her encounter with knife-wielding
psychopath Michael Myers that she'd spent
the ensuing years drinking her pain away while
training herself and her family for a second
showdown with the one we've come to call "The
Shape."
That showdown indeed came in the blood-spattered
madness of Green's Halloween.
When it happened, Laurie and company eventually
trapped the murderous Myers inside a burning
house.
Of course, Michael Myers isn't that easy to
kill.
The basement cage clearly didn't hold, since
the grisly gang is back for a pair of sequels
that will end the saga of Laurie Strode and
Michael Myers.
Now a couple of weeks into filming, Halloween
Kills is the first of those expected sequels
and if Curtis' teaser is any indication, things
are heating up on set.
Like, literally heating up, as it appears
the Halloween Kills team has already shot
Michael's escape from the burning basement.
At one point in the video, Michael is seen
standing on the porch of Laurie's house, fire
ablaze behind him, with what appears to be
a torrential downpour (or perhaps firefighter's
water hoses) damping the raging flames.
If you're wondering what this video might
reveal about the horrors Laurie and her family
are facing in Halloween Kills, well, there's
really not that much we can glean from it.
As of the making of this video, the plots
to both Halloween Kills and Halloween Ends
are being kept under wraps.
While Green and McBride have both been candid
about their sequels bringing an end to the
Laurie Strode-Michael Myers saga, they have
categorically refused to tip their hands as
to whether either character will make it out
alive, or if they'll both meet their ultimate
dooms.
Clearly, Laurie underestimated Michael's mortality
in 2018's Halloween as she did on two separate
occasions as a teen in the original movie.
That means in the coming sequels she'll likely
be forced to reckon with the notion that her
decades of prep may have been for naught.
We can only hope she's got a backup plan to
deal with Michael.
For now, all we can really do is hope that
David Gordon Green and the Halloween Kills
and Halloween Ends crew are bringing as much
fire and fury to the sequels as they did to
the 2018 flick.
We'll get our first look at those sequels
in a little under a year's time, when Halloween
Kills hits theaters on October 16, 2020 with
Halloween Ends arriving almost exactly a year
later on October 15, 2021.
Until then, stay tuned to Looper and Jamie
Lee Curtis' social media accounts, evidently
for updates on Halloween Kills.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
horror films are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.